una victoria histórica que lo convierte
en una leyenda aún más grande por 16
años Lionel Messi ha jugado en mundiales
primero con el rótulo de revelación pero
luego con el del mejor jugador de todos
los tiempos un título que aficionados
compañeros e incluso buena parte de la
prensa le asignan sin que una copa del
mundo lo hubiera respaldado hasta este
domingo que tras vencer a Francia junto
a la selección argentina ahora podrá
mirar de tú a tú a la gran leyenda del
fútbol argentino de guardando Maradona
el jugador que se echó al hombro a un
equipo no particularmente virtuoso para
sacarlo campeón en México 86 Aunque a
diferencia de Maradona que arrasó con su
genialidad a la Selección del 86 Messi
ha estado acompañado en Qatar por
jugadores que muchos consideran entre
los mejores en este mundial como Nicolás
otamendi o revelaciones como Enzo
Fernández y Julián Álvarez es una
generación que ha crecido a la sombra de
Messi un hombre que suma un oro olímpico
Champions 7 balones de oro 10 títulos de
la Liga de España con el Barcelona y uno
con Francia en el psg y que lo acompañó
en condiciones de igualdad al título de
la Copa América de 2021 de Indonesia
bangladesh o en su natal Rosario muchos
levantaban la copa antes de esta final
anticipando el festejo con el que toda
Argentina está soñando en estos momentos
él es y se merece lo mejor de la vida
porque es una personita hermosa
eso no lo es un líder nato Lionel Messi
el hombre que entendió que la magia no
está reñida con la efectividad
finalmente consiguió subir en su último
mundial a un podio que el imaginario
futbolístico le concedió hace mucho
tiempo ahora un poco más arriba como
Astro del fútbol